Oh coffee on a Tuesday in block 15 hello
to everybody who is new speaking for the
hard 500 who were here before and myself
welcome for generosity during the
project for awesome expanded my
conception of what could be done in this
community and though it's not enough
clearly I can only say thank you oh and
there's
[Music]
okay so now that that's done I think the
president wanted to say something my
fellow Americans major combat operations
any right wait wait wait no no not that
per so as your commander-in-chief and on
behalf of a grateful nation I'm proud to
finally say these two words and I know
your families agree welcome home
yes yes yes yes the war in Iraq is over
December 15th 2011 eight years and 270
days later by certainly it's 2004 I
think the war seemed about is smart to
most as deliberately putting your hand
on a sizzling pan we have to be careful
about simplifying a complex second
because it will be left to us nine years
later to appraise this war to tell its
story in a way which is loyal to the
truth but also answerable to the four
thousand four hundred and eighty-seven
troops who gave their lives to it and
the many more thousands who gave their
arms with their legs or their ability to
use either but that I am NOT gonna talk
about the war proper what I want to talk
about is what happens when you burn your
fingers on a sizzling pan if it's
happened to you then you know that if
it's a good solid burn then some of your
skin is gonna stay on that pan and as
troops leave Iraq there's a bit of our
collective skin which will stay in that
country for some time there are roughly
16,000 Americans still in Iraq to aid
with the ongoing diplomatic effort there
and effort which is primarily aimed at
making sure we secure an alliance with
the young democratic government we
worked so hard and spent so much to put
in place Iraq is particularly important
because it sits on the largest oil
reserve in the world according to new
seismic data and with so much
uncertainty in the region because of the
Arab Spring Iraq remains a very
strategic Ally
so the 16,000 are split up like this
2000 diplomats and 14,000 civilian
contractors half of those contractors
are there for general life support
everything from transportation to food
service at mess hall and the other half
are security contractors I want to talk
about the ladder security contractors
because you hear that term tossed around
a lot but I think a lot of people don't
really know what it means
I did the official name for the entity
is private military company or PMC
though many know them as security
contractors or even mercenaries so they
don't really like that last name
[Music]
maybe you can see why whatever you want
to call them they are corporations that
deal in the peripheral duties of war for
profit they can't engage in offensive
operations according to the Geneva
Convention though they can do almost
everything but including defensive
operations with the liberal use of the
term defense they build planes maintain
them even fly them in conflict zone they
supplied bodyguards for diplomat they
construct vast military camps operate
intelligence systems supply weapons and
ammunition and they train soldiers in
fact most security contractors are
retired soldiers men and women who come
out of combat with a set of skills
applicable nowhere else but in combat
contract companies will pay them
generously for those skills often more
than double what the army pay it's no
skin off their back because the private
military industry has boomed in the last
ten years really ever since 1991 when
the Pentagon led by then defense
secretary Dick Cheney paid a company
called Brown & Root services 8.5 million
dollars to study the use of private
military forces with soldiers in combat
zone now Brown & Root Services was a
subsidiary of Halliburton an oil company
where Cheney served as CEO between his
time as defense secretary and vice
president his study found that
outsourcing duties to private military
companies was cheap so after 9/11 when
the Bush administration announced its
war on terror the role of PMC's was
increased dramatic during combat
operations in Iraq tens of thousands of
security contractors supplied necessary
goods and services to the Troops as they
toppled Saddam's regime and when the
invasion ended and the occupation began
contractors only grew in number the
government was outsourcing its
responsibilities to the point of
confusion April 2004 for contractors
from a company called Blackwater were
killed burned and dragged through the
streets of Fallujah and central Iraq
this footage was released to the news
outlets and it prompted a revenge
mission to recapture the city operation
vigilante resolve in which 27 Americans
were killed 180 insurgents and 600 in
Raqqa civilians you see security
contractors don't have access to all the
tactical information that the troops
have yet still they carry guns and
operate within all the same theaters of
conflict they don't fall into the chain
of command so they can leave any time
they may get multimillion-dollar
contracts from the State Department but
being private companies they don't have
to provide itemized records of where the
money is gone or anything of all about
PMC's is that they don't fall under the
Uniform Code of Military Justice it's
that lack of accountability that lack of
oversight which alarms many people
questionable deaths of dozens of Iraqis
which will never be prosecuted profit as
the war
the contractors will stay indefinitely
to provide security for the embassies in
Baghdad arable Kirkuk and Basra the last
being a city 20 miles from the border of
Iran and sitting on one of the largest
oil fields in the world yes oil sexy
delicious grab shin-soo if Iran seizes
controlled in one way or another we
could see gas prices rise two five six
seven ten dollars again I think it's not
fair to say that the only reason we went
to Iraq was for the oil but there's no
doubt that in large part and with the
help of PMC's it's why we're staying
[Music]
[Applause]
hello everybody welcome to the special
end message I got some news I'm gonna be
on the last word with lawrence O'Donnell
on MSNBC Thursday night this Thursday
December 22nd at 10:00 p.m. Eastern Time
so if you want to check it out it'll be
talking about the kind fun and project
for awesome and the project for awesome
video what I need you to do is storm
John Green and Hank green so that they
know that this is happening so that I
can know that we still have time to
donate because I think this could
provide a nice big push to the project
for awesome and and that's it so thank
you very much for watching the video and
I will see you later